it's wish time time to check out if wish
is going to deliver on my needs so far
it's been a catastrophe to say the least
this is cool
i had the great idea trying to buy a
bally song
because i like them they're fun to play
with
it's awesome well don't do that do not
buy a ballast song the cops came to my
house and they told me i was bad and i
shouldn't have done that
so i'm sorry
your boy's got a criminal record let's
go
i feel like this is a culture thing like
sweden is a tool not with thing so
anyway as you can imagine quite stressed
out therefore i have found this for this
month i'm gonna buy stress relieving
items like this spinner pen pen it
relieves stress multifunction spinners a
draw it spun it spun it black
yes okay three pounds buy it okay so i
found some sort of fidget cube this
looks kind of cool i kind of like it
release stress and ex she's holding it
replace nail biting and bad habits this
is not a bad habit mom i just did that
without looking how sick was it it fits
in your pocket it fits in your pocket
got this for a birthday present
absolutely loved it all right
i trust saka trust you two pounds
bought it oh
my
god
squirrel cup tree stump shape deep
compression toy plastic animal fidget
fitness sensory toy again
oh
oh my god
yeah
oh that looks like that looks like
something
stop you can fit pens in there
new merch
everyone's been asking for it so here it
is
sweden
oh pancake
yeah
it's got japanese textile in it it's a
nice fit i actually really like it i
should have heated up the pad
[Music]
uh we also got t-shirt looking very nice
i think they killed the design on this
one probably one of my favorite ever
merch we also got
the hat that will make everyone think
you're depressed or just
feeling a little bit existential about
the fact that you're not in japan oh
cerro devs
okay i can read it finally i like
kind of at least very nice merge drop i
think you guys will like it remember to
check out merch link in the description
get it now before we stop great way to
support the channel thank you
onward video who hates this who rated
this one star get out of here okay these
are cool you need biotic arms because
they will cut them off it's a disco ball
that flies upgrade flying ball toys
globe shaped magic controller mini drone
flying toy ballet
baller volante
oh they're trying to get the frenchies i
don't know how i feel about that screw
it
buy it
10 pieces new beautiful magic
wind-up butterfly toy for for christmas
but it's not christmas
it's 5.77 i have to god that is so
expensive for this trash come on
you say all right buy it
buy it yeah
4k dual camera foldable easy to operate
newly launched okay the pursuit of
beauty has never stopped full of
sincerity
i love the tanks they're so good 20
bucks for a drone is pretty good flight
just have a hand
but i don't have hands oh wait i do it's
okay uh oh it costs more uh okay fine
fine
oh my god they got beyblades i love
beyblades i love bray blades advanced
rubber double wire transmitter okay
i'm all in it's got flame 11 pounds yeah
you bet you're sweet ass okay cool you
can buy uh
like the arena seven pounds seems like a
lot but i'ma buy it you gill cards that
seems like a bad idea i feel like you're
just gonna get a bunch of trash
dark magician girl i'm in
what a specific price 267 oh hell yeah
this looks actually kind of sick
seven colors buy it oh
oh
oh
came almost on time almost
almost yo we even got a tail though hell
yeah alright so again don't buy knives
and i'll see you guys in the future
welcome future here
very big boy let's see what's inside
okay
there was a hole already
i never remember
what i bought what is this oh god i got
so much stuff
i don't know if these uh zip codes and
blick holes will get me
dogs but i'm willing to give it a
shot holy [ __ ] i bought so much
i bought yu-gi-oh cards
yeah
better look chaos i bet you these are
like ones that have already been open or
something
oh maybe not yeah
somebody got a [ __ ] hole in it it's
not supposed to have a hole in it
cool let me guess it's all [ __ ]
oh wow start this dragon
yeah and they're not supposed to be
upside down either that does not happen
wow
yeah
well that's worth a billion guys all
right you get fake
i don't know why you expect buying cards
from wish yugioh nerds you you tell me
yeah why are they upside down they
literally come on blue eyes jet dragon
okay kind of lit to be honest thank you
chinese man random chinese man was like
he will like this card he will
appreciate it all right let's do a big
one
what is this
oh
let's go
oh
where am i wearing this [ __ ] okay
i gotta transform
[Music]
yeah
can we zoom
[Music]
[Music]
this is so crazy
oh
this is [ __ ] prime cringe jesus
christ
but also
i look good
all right let's open the rest of these
packages yes
what a nice package it came in
wow
oh i can't believe you met in such good
quality all the way from china come and
collect them all
i will come it glow
whoa
that's kind of cool
it's like a harry potter [ __ ]
i nearly died
that's not so bad we got some fake cards
we got an epic outfit halloween costume
sorted let's continue we can only go
down
what else we got
what is this
oh
is it it's my beyblade
heck yeah i've always wanted to have
epic beyblades
whoa
sick today good day man okay it already
worked like
that's it
whoa okay this one's cool look at that
it don't fit though bro 90s toys are the
best
look rip
yeah
edgar will love this they give me so
many
i feel like i'm gonna break it every
time i put it in i got i got more of
these what i got so many what is all
this thing it's a ball
okay some instructions would be helpful
what in the world
uh
yeah
sure
sure man
whoa
put them aside i got more [ __ ]
oh okay i remember now i bought a bunch
of stuff because clearly like i like to
fiddle
a lot
i can't help it
[Music]
so i thought why not just fiddle with
some other stuff
is this fiddle worthy
what is it this supposed to be something
it is a squirrel that's so cute
yeah i kind of like it
why is that making me laugh it's so
stupid okay i like it i actually like
that [ __ ] there's some good stuff today
we also have these luminous goggles
illumination activated look at these
pewdiepie brandon
let's go
dicey kidneys
hell
yeah
that's what i'm talking about
great five
oh
elliott these are dope hand spinner
multifunction they sent me two
why i don't know thank you chinese man
oh oh i'm gonna like this oh this is
nice i don't understand oh
oh it's like a fidget spinner oh how
does it work though
oh that's it
oh that's the best spot
i can spin these two you know
we got the pewdiepie branded one
so it's a pen
and the light
close your eyes okay now prepare for
cool
[ __ ]
hell yeah china delivers what on earth
is this
more beyblade i knew there was more
that's why i didn't mess with all this
stuff beyblade
oh it's been to spain apparently again
that the package really
fantastic quality here
okay this got the more traditional one
no instructions but if a child can do it
then maybe i can also do it
oh this is heavier this is the stuff i
want i want the stuff that maybe makes
the cops come to my house like i always
thought beyblade could be so cool if
they use like knives and
i can't figure it out guys i'm sorry
whoa is it
no freaking way that's so cool
there you go
it's like actual sparks
it smells it smells like cancer i like
it i'll i'll i'll figure it out i'm
definitely smarter now flaying flying
butterfly flies up 20 feet i've always
wanted a flying better flag
they gave me so many flying better
flavors alright here we go
playing butterfly
three two
20 feet in the air they said playing
butterfly attempt to
wow
wow wow wow
that was really cool and i'm so glad i
have so many of them that i can use them
whoa look guys 20 feet in the air
playing better play
oh look yes
so i actually want to play this with
margie
there it is
i gotta get them to work
but in the meantime let's open all the
boxes i think this is supposed to be
like another one of those satisfaction
things okay it's a box that can also
become
uh smocks
and it can also become a box again
now
i don't like it why is there two of them
goddamn chinese mane why is there two of
them
maybe this is different
whoa wait it changed color
yes that actually looks cool okay
not bad not bad chinese man your
redemption this has to be good it's the
drone
one button obstacle avoidance action
smack [ __ ]
i've charged it for five minutes that
should be enough
engage
[Music]
when it sinks pretty easily
[Music]
it works pretty well i think
[Music]
whoa did you say that
[Music]
do that
[Music]
again yeah
[Applause]
check this out
[Music]
basically did a flip that's pretty cool
clear winner
all right two balls
two balls never done before this is for
you chinese man
two balls
terrifying you basically have these
random moving objects that will cut you
come on
[Laughter]
why i don't understand okay i got it
you click it in and then you spin that's
very satisfying oh
okay so if they attack each other they
get destroyed okay let's try that
damn that was a good spin here comes the
opponent
yeah
that's what i'm talking about
whoa we gotta win that
i'm such a child subscribe yeah
smash like nia
and i'll see you guys in the next
episode
near fist